las autoridades no han escatimado
esfuerzos en la búsqueda de
desaparecidos la maquinaria pesada
retira grandes troncos y excava en medio
del lodo para despejar el camino que
conecta al Estado de Río de Janeiro con
la ciudad portuaria de santos en el
estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil
la cifra de muertos y personas
desaparecidas sigue en aumento producto
de las inundaciones y deslizamientos de
tierra que iniciaron el fin de semana un
suceso que ocurrió justo cuando un gran
grupo de turistas acudían en masa a las
playas durante el feriado anual del
carnaval en una zona turística que
frecuentan las personas adineradas que
buscan estar alejados de las fiestas
callejeras masivas en las grandes
ciudades
había un ruido fuerte Entonces mi hijo
fue a verlo y cuando llegó mi balcón ya
se había caído y estaba rompiendo la
pared nuestra salvación fue la
curiosidad de mi hijo de ir a mirar de
lo contrario estaríamos todos muertos
Y aunque 7,5 toneladas de artículos de
ayuda con alimentos agua y kits de
higiene ya se han distribuido entre las
víctimas según el gobierno local
1730 personas han sido desplazadas y más
de 800 quedaron sin hogar y mientras las
fuerzas armadas se han unido para la
búsqueda de desaparecidos se espera que
la Marina sume esfuerzos de Socorro a
partir del jueves ganaremos refuerzos en
la atención sanitaria a los heridos con
la llegada de un barco de la marina de
Brasil Que funcionará como hospital de
campaña con hasta 300 camas de
enfermería y con profesionales de
ortopedia psiquiatría traumatología y
medicina en general
las recientes inundaciones se suman a
una serie de desastres de este tipo que
han golpeado a Brasil en los últimos
años analistas apuntan que mientras la
calidad de la construcción en las
laderas no se mejore este escenario
podría seguirse repitiendo en temporada
de lluvias